un qui vont à singer
j'ai dû vous voir déguisés et alors je
sais pas quoi vous étiez déguisé en
cosmonaute à s'est elle avait refusé un
bleu un fruit et vous enduits des
copains là tout de suite jeudi ils vont
pas se penser que je fais une émission
comme ça où il faut se déguiser de la
télé réalité un peu des ébats tout de
suite je traduis lé palmade je pensais
pas qu'ils valaient pensé que j'en étais
au point de faire une image
[Rires]
pour être honnête j'y suis allé un peu
pour l'argent et je suis reparti en 10
ans là bas je me suis bien marré
alors c'est vrai et je crois que ce truc
30000 euros
jusqu'à 50 sinon ce serait 30000 euros
là sur le sommeil lent il faut réussir
sur françois hollande c'est clément
guérin qui mena trente six mille euros
de retraite mensuelle françois hollande
tout le monde a confondu c'est le
président le plus payé de la 5e puis qui
coûte le plus cher à l'état
voilà vous ajoutez des conférences et
compagnie à la pomme dans la penderie et
débrouille sap a quand même sympa quand
même voilà
voilà pas vous oui non mais non
seulement il a l'honnêteté de dire ça
non plus modéré françois hollande tous
les candidats masse singer le font pour
l'argent mais encore participent aux
meilleurs pâtissiers qu'on aime la
pétition va pas venir jeu qui fait
faucon non mais voilà sans et google le
concert de sting heures c'est rien donc
on ne le faire que pour l'argent et en
plus c'est une émission qui par
définition apporte très peu de
visibilité puisqu'on ne voit pas sauf à
la fin donc il faut tout ça pour
l'argent et ils prennent effectivement
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'euros
voilà il a le surnom mais c'est sûr que
tu dois pas vrai je vais faire ma
stingers ont collé ma carrière dans des
tentes non mais sans déconner c'est vrai
et dans une chouette en train de chanter
river iriver babylone la du bonnet aime
faire on va pas taper pour faire des
films mais c'est vrai on va pas dire
[ __ ] j'ai vu dans la chouette de masse
singer
alaïa un talent est là mais je te dis on
en a rien à carrer assuré que les
incessantes quand vous quand vous
arrivez vous enregistrez votre chanson
en studio donc évidemment c'est un
playback quand vous êtes dedans je suis
donc il ya juste 2 3 après vous vous
faites ça en bob l'eponge et c'est tout
alors que danse avec les stars par
exemple vu ses huit heures c'est ça un
jour ils ont la princesse haya rien à
faire chez sur ses skis je pense que
sans regarder l'émission peut avoir des
a priori mais en la regardant j'ai
trouvé ça super chouette parce qu'en
fait au final chacun d'entre nous rêvent
de de monter sur scène et de chanter et
en fait
j'ai rêvé de monter sur scène
cerise sur des
données tandis que quand tu as une
carapace non c'est gros c'est très bien
que les artistes qui est ce qu'ils
aiment c'est qu'on les voit sa monnaie
c'est qu'on les maquis c'est qu'on les
applaudissent qu'il y ait un signal dans
une épreuve comme une voiture et à la
fin dix minutes c'était moi
mais tu imagines devant ta famille sans
décoller famille tu appelles étonnant
mais c'est moi et eux d'y jeter derrière
ans bob l'eponge dans ma famille des
enfants d'investir avec coline aumard
est moi je suis à mon compte pas on a
tous besoin de bouffer
pas delphine je pense qu'il a raison je
préfère je préfère être dans le qatar
voilà c'est bien avec six mois voilà
chômé chiche en difficulté vraiment je
préfère aller livrer avait créé leur
intention sim donne trente mille jr
moi je reconnais à contenu je préfère
aller livrer le tour mais oui c'est
mieux
tu rigoles rappelé à ces dernières les
mecs c'est fou ce gars c'est vrai et
déjà il va mais pas me jeter des pierres
secoue
le jour où vous propose blé pour ge à 30
milles sur une tête décembre chez vous
cave qui se sera passé il ya eu un petit
problème et ça n'est pas prêt d'oublier
la minute
toi je viendrai avec toi tu vas [ __ ]
on va rigoler tu vas m'attends quand je
serai au bout du rouleau
[Applaudissements]
déjà avancé qu'une daniel
cette émission fait pas que du bien